in washington where it is truly make or
break time this morning for president
biden's social agenda the president was
supposed to leave the white house just
hours from right now on a trip to europe
but instead he's pushing that trip back
a little as he tries to get a final
agreement among democrats on his build
back better package
many of the most popular proposals in
the bill appear to have been cut
including paid family leave and attacks
on billionaires ed o'keefe is at the
white house for us ed good morning to
you i don't understand everything about
politics but cutting popular things
seems like a bad idea
yeah we'll see tony good morning the
president expected to outline the
framework of a new plan to pass his
social policy and climate change agenda
later this morning in a meeting with
congressional democrats on capitol hill
and then in a speech to the american
public and as he heads to europe the
hope is that congress will begin passing
it this caps weeks of prolonged talks
among democrats about the details of the
legislation and it's exposed deep
divisions and while they're on the verge
of a compromise still seems like nobody
is happy
the problem is not with the president
the problem is with members here vermont
senator bernie sanders slamming two key
moderates west virginia's joe manchin
and arizona's kirsten cinema for slowing
down passage of president biden's agenda
though they are very few in number they
are a significant minority think that
they have a right
to determine
what the rest of the congress should be
doing while there's agreement on big
portions of the legislation negotiators
signaled late wednesday that plans to
provide paid leave for working americans
have to be dropped amid mansion's
concerns about costs but that didn't
stop fellow democrats from trying to
change his mind paid leave's not in the
bill it would be devastating it'd be
devastating for working women and
working parents a recent cbs news poll
showed 73 percent of americans support
federal funding for paid family and
medical leave mansion also raised
questions about a plan to pay for the
legislation with a proposed billionaire
tax saying it unfairly targets the
nation's most wealthy instead he's
pushing a 15 percent minimum tax there's
a patriotic duty that you should be
paying something to this great country
to give you the protection and the
support and the opportunities meanwhile
thousands of workers could be furloughed
if federal highway funding expires on
sunday congress could pass a new
short-term highway bill or the house
could give final approval to that
massive bipartisan infrastructure bill
that the senate passed over the summer
but dozens of house progressives say
they won't do that until they see the
actual text of any agreement on the
president's social spending plan we
can't have a situation where there's any
opportunity for misunderstanding
all right well one way or another it
seems like this bill is going to get a
pretty big haircut where does it leave
democrats what can they really get done
well look we focus on what's not in it
they will talk about what is universal
pre-kindergarten across the country big
ambitious plans to fight climate change
historic in nature and then the price
tag but by not including things like
lowering prescription drug prices or
paid parental leave look at what our
poll says 73 of americans support doing
that they won't be able to put it in
there because of the cost let's see if
there is some kind of political cost for
not doing so two key early tests of that
will be next week when there are
governors races in new jersey and
virginia they'll set the table for next
year's congressional elections tony
as always time will tell ed thank you